hello ndc how you all doing out there
and uh
welcome uh to a talk
that is uh build in the program as plain
text
and uh
i'm interested i'm always interested why
people are like oh plain text i want to
listen to that for an hour
because uh the question that i have for
all of you is is there such a thing as
plain text so a little quick intro this
is me um i'm sure some of you know who i
am because i have a feeling you're not
here because you love the plain text but
uh
i run versatile which is my online
software training and consultancy
company i'm a microsoft mvp i run a net
user group and i invented the rockstar
programming language as a joke because i
think everybody in the world should be
able to be a rockstar programmer because
then recruiters are going to have to
stop talking about that like it actually
means something and yes the title of
this talk is plain text we're going to
talk about text now you know you say to
a developer hey you know you like code
and computers and all kinds of stuff
what do you think about text you know
it's like going to someone who likes
cars i mean what do you think about
metal against someone who's into diving
and boat to me what's your opinion on
water it's like it's ubiquitous it's
everywhere everything we do involves
manipulating uh text files in various
ways and so we never really kind of
stopped to think about how all of these
encoding systems and text formats and
things that we ended up with where did
they come from and you know why do you
keep finding these weird little quirks
when you have a file you think you
should be able to read but you can't and
it's just plain text so how can it
possibly go wrong now
the thing about technology
is uh what makes it interesting and
useful and exciting and wonderful is
that a human being somewhere can have an
idea or a thought or some kind of thing
that they want to communicate
and we can take that idea and we can put
that into some technology and then the
technology can do something with it it
can search it or index it or render it
or a train a machine learning network
with it or put it in an email and send
it to australia but sooner or later it
comes back out the other end and
somebody else can share that idea and
fundamentally whenever we use computers
to store data manipulate data
communicate that's what we're doing we
are taking weird analog thoughts and
concepts and stuff from the world around
us the stuff that matters to us human
beings and we're turning it into
technology and then we're getting it
back out at the other end and somebody
else is going oh yeah that's cool now
we invented writing text uh well
actually about 5 000 years ago human
beings invented writing on clay we may
have invented writing on paper earlier
than that we don't know because the
paper would not have survived in the
archaeological record but it looks like
about 5 000 years ago human beings in a
mesopotamia in what is now iraq started
using clay tablets to send messages and
keep logs of who owed who how many goats
and how much grain and all these kinds
of things and we kind of rattled along
with that for about four four and a half
thousand years but it didn't get
interesting until we invented
electricity and then someone went hey
what if we put these things together
what if we do a mash-up of writing and
electricity and they came up with this
the cooking wheatstone telegraph system
this was used in england in the 1830s
and i think it is the first instance
anywhere in history of text being
encoding into some kind of electrical
messaging system now cooking wheatstone
was really interesting for a lot of
reasons there's a lot of stuff about
this project which will sound familiar
to a lot of the people in this room cook
was a business person and cook was an
entrepreneur and wheatstone was a
scientist he invented a thing called the
wheatstone bridge if any of you have
heard of that um and cook was like this
thing needs to be really really
expensive and wheatstone's like no we
must give our technology away to the
world for free
and cook is like it has to be really
really simple so that people don't need
training and wheatstone's like we're
literally about to revolutionize human
communications surely people can be
expected to read the manual first and so
they have to go backwards and forwards
but they eventually came up with a
design that looked like this now
the cook and wheatstone system used five
cables the first installation of this
was in west london between paddington
railway station and a place called west
drayton which is about 20 kilometers
distance so they had to run five wires
each wire is 20 kilometers long using
state-of-the-art technology in 1830
which is copper wrapped up in a thing
called gutta-percha which is made from
the bark of a tree we're not talking
fiber optic here and you know what
you've got to remember you can't call
ahead and say hey the cable's arriving
tomorrow because that doesn't exist yet
so if you want to get a message to
someone and say we're bringing a cable
through you need to send a horse
so they run these five cables five
cables 20 kilometers long and the way
that the system worked it has these five
little magnetic needles across the
middle of the dial and if you wanted to
send somebody a letter you would push a
key on the keyboard at one end and two
of these needles would deflect because
the key would close a circuit between
one pair of cables so you'd have a
positive charge on one negative coming
back on the other two needles would move
and then you would read off the dial
where do they cross so it could encode
24 letters of the alphabet uh it didn't
do uh k and it didn't do no it didn't do
c and it didn't do uh i can't remember
the other one q i think um but there are
24 letters which was enough to send
messages and this thing made headlines
when they used it to catch a murderer
somebody tried to escape the police by
jumping on a train at paddington and
they telegraphed ahead and had the
police waiting when they got there and
it made news like amazing telegraph you
know can communicate faster than a train
and that was a big deal in 1834. um now
like i said this is the earliest
encoding system i i was able to find for
this talk and uh it's a five symbol
trinary encoding system
so if you're ever scratching your head
with like 8-bit binary ascii and you're
thinking uh eight bits is actually a
little bit cumbersome to work with
imagine if we had had a system where
every character is encoded using five
symbols each of which can be positive
negative or zero now i think we you know
as a society we kind of dodged that
bullet the problem with the telegraph
system is those five wires eventually
one of them broke
and so somebody's like we need to run a
new wire and someone else we still got
four wires can we come up with a
telegraph system that works with only
four and they did and then one of those
broke and someone said well could we
come up with a three-wire system and
meanwhile across the other side of the
atlantic in the united states a guy
called samuel morse was starting with
one wire he didn't even have one coming
back the other way he's like well the
ground is the ground so that's your your
life ground is the ground and we are
going to send signals on that and he
invented this which i'm sure all of you
recognize even if you've never used it
um now this is not actually the morse
code that was invented by samuel morse
this is a variant on that which is
called international morse code it was
invented in germany by an engineer
called friedrich gerker about 10 years
after samuel morse invented his system
and
they had a conference in paris in 1965
to agree some teleca telecom standards
for the emerging telegraph network that
was being built across europe and they
signed off on this international most
code all the companies and countries
that were building telegraph systems
were like yes we will use this one now
if you've ever built a product or
shipped any kind of api or service
you'll know that when nobody is using
your stuff you can change it as often as
you like because nobody cares
but as soon as you have real users in
the real world using your system anytime
you change anything they get a bit upset
now international morse code arrived at
just the right time that within about a
decade every single telegraph system on
the planet one had just been built you
know this was the decade when telegraphy
swept the world and two they were all
using this system except for the united
states of america which has always done
its own thing when it comes to
international cooperation but everyone
else was using international morse code
and so it survived this thing proved
almost impossible to replace with
anything better it wasn't the best
encoding system but everyone knew it
telegraph operators were familiar with
it worked on a single wire you could
send it over cables you could also send
it using sound you could send it using
lights and signaling lamps and all kinds
of things and so this wasn't unseated
until almost exactly 100 years later
1965
when digital computers arrived on the
scene and
people were like we probably need a text
encoding system that works well with
binary computers now the reason morse
code doesn't you might look at that and
think well dot dash dot dash morse code
is not just dot dash morse code also
includes timing to decode a morse code
message you need to be able to count the
gaps between the messages or look for
the spaces between them so there is
actually more to it than just a dot and
a dash it's not a binary system
computers like binary true false one
zero and so a bunch of people sat down
in america the american standards
association which became later became
ansi and they're like we are going to
invent an encoding system for putting
text into computers now the computers
they were thinking about looked like
this
they did not have screens they had tele
types teleprinters and they didn't have
disks they had punch cards now they did
a kind of reasonable job this was the
project that gave the world ascii the
american standard code for information
interchange and you know we've all
worked with ascii right but have you
ever taken ascii apart and tried to work
out why it looks the way it does and why
it works that way
ascii is a 7-bit encoding system
now here is the bottom block of ascii
the first 32 characters in the ascii
table um zero is all the zeros and that
is null any c plus plus or c developers
in the room because we still use that
null terminated strings is one of those
things that was the best idea we had at
the time and now it's just never going
away
but then you get into a block of
characters that were designed to control
these 1965 teleprinters now if you
wanted to send an instruction to your
teleprinter there was a key on your
keyboard called control and you pushed
control and then if you want to send a
one for start of heading you center
control a if you wanted to send a start
of text you press ctrl b if you wanted
to send end of text as in stop printing
stuff because you're not supposed to be
printing because i've made a mistake in
my program you'd send control c and that
one has survived to this day as the
interrupt character on almost all
development platforms then we've got end
of transmission inquiry acknowledgement
ascii code number seven if you open a
terminal on a windows machine and you
type echo space push control g and press
enter it will play ping dot wav because
that's how they interpret the
instruction to ring the bell on the tele
printer on windows 11 and that still
works and then we get into the tabs and
the you know the the line feeds and
these kinds of characters and by the way
character 11 vertical tab is the correct
answer to the tabs versus spaces
argument if anyone ever tries to have
that with you
now
this block here we've got a carriage
return and we've got a line feed and
mechanical teleprinters if you look at
the way a teleprinter works it has a
thing called a carriage and when you
print a line of text
the carriage is going to move across and
print things and then you get to the end
you're like well i need to return the
carriage to the start of the line and
then i need to feed another line of
paper through the teleprinter now these
things were very primitive they used
like a daisy wheel style typewriter head
they couldn't do bold they couldn't do
italics but they could do a kind of
pseudo bold because what you could do is
you could print a line you could do a
carriage return and then you could print
the same line again and you'd get this
kind of bold over printed effect so a
carriage return without a new line was
actually used a lot a new line without a
carriage return
very occasionally but honestly it was
kind of useless and so we ended up with
the scenario when uh if you look at the
state of the art today
we have linux and unix machines and we
have mac os and we have android and they
say slash n is a new line and we have
windows 10 11 8 7 vista xp and they say
no a new line is slash r slash n and the
reason for this is that most unix
systems or you know linux android those
kind of systems they evolved from unix
and unix evolved from a system called
multix and multix was the first
operating system in history that had
device drivers so they had a little
place where they could run a piece of
code that said hey if you're talking to
a teleprinter and you see a slash n put
in a slash r as well because obviously
we want to return the carriage before we
print the next line whereas windows
evolved out of well ms-dos and ms-dos
kind of ripped off a lot of ideas from
cpm and cpm was designed to run on
really cheap mini computers which didn't
have any device driver capability and so
that's why to this day the major
operating systems in the world cannot
agree on what the end of a line looks
like is because they came from these two
very different schools of abstraction
and hardware engineering now
we take a look at the next chunk one of
the interesting decisions that the
creators of ascii had to make is they're
like we are allowed 127 characters and
we've lost 32 of them to control codes
what are we going to include and they
did some things like does anyone work in
typesetting or typography
where you have a you know in ascii we
have a dash and that dash it's a minus
sign and it's a dash um and it's a and
dash and it's an m dash all these
different different kinds of things in
publishing those are different
characters you have an m dash and you
have an n dash and they're different
widths and a minus sign is not the same
as a hyphen the creators of ascii were
like actually we don't need that stuff
and so they just come up with one little
horizontal line and you can use that for
whatever you need but within the last
sort of ten years particularly as
e-books and high-definition displays
have become popular we are starting to
see a return to some of this uh you know
typographic characters smart quotes is
another good example ascii didn't have
space for an open quote and a close
quote so it just doubled them up and now
we're starting to see those come back in
which is why if you copy and paste code
out of microsoft word into visual studio
it never works because it's broken all
the quotes for you right
now this block here starting at 48 these
are the decimal numbers and one of the
things that computer has to do a lot is
it's got to turn numbers that are
actually text which are what human
beings can read into numbers that are
actually numbers so it can do arithmetic
with them and the way ascii does this is
you chop off the top half of basically
the biggest four bits and what you're
left with is the binary representation
of that digit so the code for the
character zero the bottom four bits of
that are the binary values zero one is
one two is two and this is blisteringly
fast even on a 4-bit microprocessor like
the intel 404 so this was a really kind
of nice optimization now you get to the
alphanumeric or the alphabetic
characters you ever wondered why
uppercase a and ascii is 65 and
lowercase a is 97. like why did they
pick those two numbers and the reason is
they are separated by one bit
so if you have an ascii text file and
you want to do a case insensitive sort
or string comparison or something you
just ignore the sixth bit and then they
come out the same that's why they are 32
characters apart in the index we mop up
a little bit more punctuation with you
know a vertical bar and a tilde and
stuff and then finally we get to
character number 127 which is ascii
delete dell which looks like this
and the reason ascii dell looks like
that is you can't fill in the holes on a
punch card the only way to erase
information from a punch guard is to
punch out all the rest of the holes as
well and that's why ascii delete is a
block of ones because you send this to a
card punch and it punches out all the
holes and then you can't read what was
on the card anymore and so the united
states slaps themselves on the back and
they're like hey good job everyone 127
characters is all you'll ever need and
the rest of the world goes what
we can't even work i mean some countries
and cultures were like well you've
missed the last four letters of our
alphabet but okay well we'll work with
this for a while other countries and
cultures are like this thing we're not
even like we can't even get out of bed
with this thing like literally there is
no way our culture can use your standard
to communicate now
my personal journey with plain text is a
story of three turning points and the
first of those came in about 1988 1989
i grew up in zimbabwe where you know i
grew up speaking english and using
dollars and cents so the early computers
that i played around with i didn't have
any encoding problems because i used all
the characters that the americans used
when i moved to the united kingdom when
i was about 10 years old i was trying to
print some homework and i tried to print
this
and it didn't work
and it didn't work because the americans
did not give us a standard for the pound
sign the pound sterling currency symbol
because they didn't use it and so my
computer was using one set of
abstractions to do pound signs but my
printer which was like one meter away on
the desk connected by a cable that was
using a completely different system and
that's when i started having to learn
about something called code pages
because ascii is a 7-bit encoding system
and a whole lot of people kind of looked
at it and they went well we've got this
alphabet that we like and the americans
have used the bottom half but we've got
eight bits in a byte
maybe
we could use this bit to send emails in
uh bulgarian cyrillic or uh hebrew or
whatever it is that they wanted to use
and lots of people said is anyone using
this bit and no one said please don't
and so they all invented their own ways
of doing it every single one of those is
a code page that's what a code page is a
set of rules we're saying this is what
the top half of 8-bit ascii means right
here right now in this document on this
computer and often that's not the same
as on this document on the printer that
is right next to it now
one of the most common uh or sort of
popular i guess infamous is probably a
good word code pages in history was code
page 437 there you go you're literally
listening to a guy right now talk about
his favorite code pages how do you feel
about that code page 437 shipped with
the ibm pc in the 1980s and uh it's
interesting for two reasons one
they extended ascii to support most of
what western europe needed so they
included all of the accent characters
necessary for you know the nordic
languages eastern europe french
then they included half of the greek
alphabet
not all of it they included the half
that shows up in physics
so all the letters of the greek alphabet
that are used in mainstream kind of high
school level physics are in code page
437 but you can't use it to write
documents in greek because it doesn't
have enough letters
and then they went well the ibm pc
doesn't actually have a teleprinter so
we probably don't need that bottom
control thing let's override that and
use it so we've got smiley faces and
playing card symbols and all those kinds
of things and if you've ever seen an ibm
pc crash really really hard and you get
a screen full of gibberish and smiley
faces and playing cards that's because
it's gone completely you know the
operating system kernel has crashed it's
sending control codes just trying to
stop the teleprinter and it's going oh
yeah smiley face clearly that's a good
way of communicating what happened now
there were a whole bunch of different
code pages created for different
alphabets and different languages but
they didn't always solve the problem
terribly well uh one that i'm
particularly interested in is code pages
used for the cyrillic alphabet which is
used in russia ukraine belarus and
bulgaria i think and you know a bunch of
other countries as well now there was an
international um encoding system which
was created kind of you know ratified by
ansi for doing russian in 8-bit ascii
where you would take a word like a
priviet which is high in in russian and
you'd turn it into a bunch of 8-bit
sequences but
a lot of systems at the time would chop
off the first bit they would either just
not bother transmitting it or they'd use
it for parity checks or they'd use it
for things like has this word been spell
checked those kinds of things email
systems word star quite a lot of
bulletin board systems could not cope
with the eighth bit and so that would
disappear it would get chopped off and
what you'd get out the other side was a
bunch of numbers that when you turn them
back into text
gibberish doesn't mean anything at all
so the russians when this system is no
good we're going to create a better
system and this was a brilliant hack it
was the the code obnemer infomatia
vocembit 8-bit encoding system what they
did they said we'll take the russian
alphabet and instead of encoding it in
alphabetical order we'll encode it using
the english letters which kind of sound
the same
and so what you do is you take privet
you run it through your 7-bit word star
spell check it chops off the top bits
and what you get at the other side is
that
and they transpose the upper and lower
case so it's obvious that this thing has
been mangled but you can still kind of
read it and make sense of what it says
and that that's the kind of ingenious
hack that i absolutely love now
you can go down all kinds of rabbit
holes when it comes to
russian and ascii there's a story i did
this talk at a conference a couple of
months ago and someone emailed me
afterwards and said
do you know about the harry potter
envelope and i was like what's the harry
potter envelope and they sent me the
story and i did a bit of research what
happened this is in 2002 and uh there
was an email kind of pen friend
correspondence thing going on
between a woman in russia called
svetlana and somebody in france whose
name is lost to history so i've called
her claudette and they're emailing
backwards and forwards and uh sveta says
an email to claudette saying hey that'd
be amazing yes send me the new harry
potter book we can't get it in russia
yet here's my address it's in the
russian alphabet please copy it very
carefully and includes a street address
written in a moscow street address in
russian in cyrillic and this arrives on
claudette's french computer which is
using a windows western european
encoding and it looks like
this
but the instructions say here's my
address in the russian alphabet please
copy it carefully now the underlying you
know the code points there the numeric
values are the same but it's being
rendered using a different
interpretation so uh claudette follows
the instructions and she copies that
very carefully onto an envelope
and puts it in the mail and it finds
somebody in the russian postal system
who knows what has happened who goes
through and fills it all in
and the book ends up getting delivered
now then uh how many of you in here have
got a phone in your pocket which has
spotify or apple music or itunes uh if
you do get it out now and i want you to
go on there and i want you to search for
this word
you found anything
billy joel
live in leningrad 1987 because in 1987
billy joel played a concert in the city
of leningrad which is now saint
petersburg and it was one of the
earliest western recordings to be
released inside the soviet union and so
they called the album concert but they
wrote it using the russian alphabet and
then this got sent over to some record
company who were like we need to put
this in a database
k-o-h
is that a you
in russian this is cons
but they cohu app and of course once
something's in a database it's never
coming out and so when apple music and
spotify set up all these licensing deals
with you know the big music providers
they're like do you have a database of
all your records that we can they're
like yeah i have a copy i have a big csv
file and so cohuept live in leningrad
has just become a thing now it's an
encoding problem that became a database
problem that became an album that you
can go on a spotify and listen to right
now
now
codepages worked up to a point if you
were just using your computer to do your
stuff in your language and you had your
printer set up properly that's kind of
okay um they sucked for email they
sucked for a lot of things you couldn't
write a document which combined russian
and hebrew on the same page you had to
do it as separate documents and then
staple them together and if you're not
stapling stuff because you're sending it
by email there's just no way of doing
this and there are a lot of code pages
this is the one section of the wikipedia
list of code pages because there's the
uh so mac os has well we've got one for
you know arabic one for armenian one for
cyrillic one for chinese korean and then
dos has all of its own and then ibm has
some for ax and ibm has ones that it
built for other people and postscript
has a set and this was just chaos like
if we were going to wire the planet and
connect all our computers together so we
could send email backwards and forwards
we needed a unified coding system and so
the unicode consortium was born set up
in 1988 the consortium was kind of
legally founded in 1991 and their
mission statement
which i think is a great example of a
mission statement just says this it's to
provide a single consistent way to
represent each letter and symbol needed
for all languages across all computers
and devices now a single consistent way
to represent each letter and symbol
actually we start at the end all
computers and devices well the only way
to do that is to come up with something
really really good like literally easier
than people inventing their own document
it give it away for free make it
completely free of any licensing
restrictions and then encourage people
to use it and they succeeded you know
the unicode standard is so prevalent now
it's why whatsapp works it's why signal
works it's why email works it's why the
web works they did a fantastic job and
when they said all human languages they
also wanted to include you know like
egyptian hieroglyphics and ancient
sumerians so that people who are doing
historical research can use unicode
and then we got this first part a single
consistent way to represent letters and
symbols for all human languages now
what is a letter
there's two strings here they look the
same
they're the same shape
they are not the same string they are
not even the same alphabet one of them
is the start of the russian word hirosho
the other one is the english word
exoplanet and so you get into very
quickly these kind of complicated
discussions about well if we have two
letters that look the same and they
represent the same sound but they come
from different alphabets are they the
same letter or not now i'm british i
speak british english good afternoon how
is the queen would you like some tea so
when i travel and i see words like this
what my english brain does is go oh uh
yeah i i'm just going to filter that out
because i don't know what that means and
i'm going to say good afternoon could i
have a half owner please
and i'm like what's a half owner it's a
half female is that close enough um hof
and air is a hair
in norwegian but my english brain it
just thinks that these are like extra
decoration you know like the garnish on
a cheeseburger i push them to one side
but they're not these are different
letters of the alphabet in norwegian and
swedish and danish
and so when my english brain treats it
as this i'm actually throwing away
semantically significant information
uh let's meet some friends of mine uh
this is a francois border who's a french
archaeologist and this is the los
angeles heavy metal band motley crew and
uh francois the archaeologist went to
the motley crew concert now this
sentence is written in english but it
has some things in it which do not
appear in the english alphabet we have a
a little c with a cedia here and we have
an a and an e kind of mashed together
which is still a thing some typesetters
do and then we've got a an o with an
umlaut and a u with an almond out on it
and uh that is the heavy metal umlaut
which is used by american rock bands
because they think it makes them look
cool and the first time motley crew went
to germany they could not work out why
the audience was chanting mertle akure
merkley akure
until someone had to sit them down and
go you know your name is nonsense in
this country
um now making motley crew look stupid is
not really a big deal i kind of look
stupid anyway right
but this can have real consequences
some of you probably know this guy
magnus actually you know some of you
probably know this guy magnus mortonson
who's a swedish developer as your mvp
and a couple years ago magnus was
traveling to a conference in the united
states and uh he has a swedish passport
and the rules of swedish orthography if
you look at the bottom of your passport
there's a little strip that has to be
ascii so that mainframes from the 1970s
can read it that's just the rules and
the swedish government says that if you
have the letter or which is the a with a
circle and you have to turn it into
ascii it's two a's a a and the people
who printed magnus airline ticket
they're like we just take the circle off
because we don't know what that is to
get into the us with a passport that
doesn't exactly match the name printed
on his airline ticket um how many of you
have met united states border security
they're a famously understanding bunch
aren't they
now you know magnus is a kind of
affluent white guy on his way to go and
speak at a conference at microsoft or
something so he just had to answer a
couple of questions and explain what had
happened but you can see how this kind
of texting coding problem could have
real consequences for somebody who the
authorities decide they don't like the
look of and we are just getting warmed
up
let's take a look at a list of cities
berlin zurich
and urbu
now we are going to take this list of
european cities and we are going to put
it into our sql server database insert
into city's name we've got a n-varchar
128 so we've got unicode support in the
table we're going to put all those
cities in we're going to select star
just to make sure we can get our data
back out again there we go and now what
we're going to do is select start from
cities where name equals bro
and we get nothing back and we're like
well that's not what i was expecting as
a british english person maybe it's case
sensitive or a bro with a big o nope
still nothing
well are these things even the same
no they're not by default they're not
unless you tell your database i would
like you to compare strings using the
latin one general case insensitive
accent insensitive collation which is a
set of rules for deciding whether two
letters of the alphabet are greater
lesser or the same and if we use that
correlation it says yes these are now
considered to be equivalent now what
we're going to do next is we're going to
go here we've got cities ordered by name
and we're going to use that latin
general coalition and we get at achen
orhurst berlin arab zurich comes out now
that's the order that a british english
speaker would expect kind of makes sense
but the letter or is not oh it is the
27th letter of the swedish alphabet and
so if we use the finnish and swedish
coalition
we get archenorgas berlin zurich and
then urabru comes out at the end because
it's the 27th letter of the alphabet now
if we do this with the danish and
norwegian coalition
achen and orhus now appear at the end
now how many of you in the room are
looking at going well of course that's
how it works that makes perfect sense
yeah
obviously now the reason for this
and if we put athens in you see athens
does still appear at the beginning now
there's a really interesting example the
best way that i found kind of explaining
this is uh the danish spelling reform
that took place so the city of orhus in
denmark which is a second city after
copenhagen um was called orwis
historically until 1948 when denmark
decided that it would quite like it if
its alphabet looked a little bit less
german and a little bit more kind of
swedish and norwegian and you can
probably work out why and so they took
the danish alphabet they added three new
letters to the end of it and they made a
rule that said anywhere that started
with or spelt a a was now or spelt or
with one of these so this list was then
in correct danish alphabetical order the
rules of danish orthography then in 2011
the city of oros voted to change its
name back so it could find itself on
tripadvisor and search engines more
easily
but not to change the position in the
alphabet so the list on the right is in
alphabetical order according to danish
orthographic conventions because archan
is not in denmark and so it goes at the
beginning but oros is in denmark and so
it goes at the end so your database now
needs to know for every single piece of
text it needs to know whether that is a
place person or company in scandinavia
or not to be able to get the
alphabetical ordering correct
which is technically impossible you know
there's just no way that you can do this
so if you ever do end up in a scenario
where you need to apply these things
where there are kind of cultural
precedents around orthography which are
not possible to deduce from the data you
have available the only thing you can do
is you can plug in more data and you can
put in a column that the computer uses
to sort things and then a column that it
uses to display what the human beings
are going to read and so if we put in an
additional column here called a sort
name we can override accent and put an
akin with a single a and that kind of
short circuits the put a a at the end of
the alphabet thing and we get at the
what you know would be familiar to uh
people who aren't necessarily familiar
with all of these conventions now
what this kind of goes to show there's a
lot of people i've met in tech who are
like i don't really do politics like i
just do computers and i don't worry too
much about the implications of what i'm
doing but
the technology that we use every day
operating systems databases keyboards
these are all informed by the history
and the culture and the politics that
created the problems that technology has
been asked to try and solve if you look
around for technology that is completely
apolitical there isn't any
there are all of these cultural and
historical precedents baked into the way
norwegian windows puts aardvark.txt at
the end of the list instead of the
beginning and if you don't know about
danish and swedish and norwegian
orthography and alphabets and stuff you
have no idea why it's doing that
let's take a look at this letter uh c
with a cedia now unicode says this is a
letter of the french alphabet and it
gives it a code point but in english
this isn't a letter of the alphabet it's
the letter c which exists in ascii with
a little tail hung off the bottom of it
and so unicir code says well if you want
to do it that way that's fine we'll give
you the c and we'll give you the tail
and you can glue those together yourself
now these combining characters you can
have a lot of fun with these because you
can put combining characters on
combining characters and you can put
more combining characters on top of
those ones and you can just keep
stacking them up until you end up with
zalgo text and then you can go and paste
this on stack overflow and questions
about tony the pony and stuff but it
brings up more questions about what if
there's two different ways to write the
same letter you know how do we know if
those are considered equivalent or not
we can write motley crew as m uh t l e y
c r e e or we can do it as m o unicode
combining diuresis and then when this
gets rendered your operating system will
go oh yeah put the dots on top of the
clearly that's what they were asking for
here
are these two strings equivalent because
they're not even the same length they're
not binary equivalent and again what
unicode did is they said we're not going
to tell you what's right and wrong we're
going to give you some options you can
work with if you're working in net
the way you tap into this is to use
something called normalization forms so
unicode defines four normalization forms
composed and decomposed composition
means take the string and squash it down
into the smallest possible number of
code points if you've got an o plus a
number you replace that with the letter
which looks like that in the first place
decomposition is the opposite you
stretch the thing out all the accents
get spanner into combining characters so
you make the string as big as you can
and then the k here stands for canonical
because they'd already used c to stand
for composition and canonical says
forget what they look like do they
represent the same word now uh this this
code is online you can grab this later
um if we create motley crew and net
terrible ideas but let's do it anyway um
using uh inline strings and then down
here we're going to do it by putting in
an owner combining diuresis we get two
strings and then we are going to go run
these through our comparison function
and what we get is we get two strings
out s1 equals s2 now you'll notice that
they're the same length
like.net has been oh well combining
characters don't meet our definition of
making the string longer they are not
equivalent s1 is not equal to s2 they
are binary different but they are
considered equivalent under all four
forms of unicode normalization if we
take the word plain text and we encode
that as uh normal text and we encode it
as text in little circles so you can
make your twitter handle look pretty
what we get at the other side there is
we get
two strings
that are not equal and they are not
equivalent under the non-canonical
comparisons but if we say apply the
canonical comparison it's like well yeah
they both say plain text in english so
they do represent the same string
now
the second turning point in my personal
journey with text encoding was when i
went into work one day probably about
five six years ago now and uh somebody
said to me dude i think we've been
hacked now when you work in i.t people
come up to you all the time and say they
think they've been hacked because uh
they've right-clicked on facebook and
view source and now they think that the
hackers are in the internet getting into
their computer because they watch too
many movies and i was like why do you
think we've been hacked now the person
this was not somebody prone to facebook
movie paranoia um this was one of the
best security engineers that i've ever
worked with and uh he said uh there's
chinese in the windows event logs it's a
british company in london using english
language windows with no chinese
customers no chinese business deals no
chinese employees
why is what do you mean there's chinese
in the event logs and sure enough
there is chinese in the windows event
logs and so i do what uh managers do in
that situation as i say to one person
you check the firewall see if there's
any suspicious activity or anything uh
you go and look through all the database
tables see if you can find any data like
is this an injection attack um is this
just like a weird endpoint on one of our
websites you go and tell customer
services that weirdness is going on and
we'll have a proper update for them in
15 minutes which means i can sit back
and [ __ ] post about it on twitter
and that actually solved the problem
faster than any because i i put this
little message up and i was like oh it's
gonna be one of those days and
immediately i got a couple of replies
back from people going oh that looks
like a unicode mapping error and then
the fake unicode twitter account which
is a lot of fun you should follow it
pops up and says yeah the low bits are
null so this is probably utf-16le being
mistaken for udf-16be
and i'm going right
i should probably figure out really fast
what those things are
and so i dive headfirst into the unicode
rabbit hole and a couple of hours later
i sort of stumble out bemused and
blinking and figure out what's going on
the word delete
internally windows and java and
javascript they use 16 bits for almost
everything because it is fast with uh
you know native operating system running
on the hardware in front of you network
speed is not a big deal compared to
being able to manage stuff effectively
in memory and so they use 16 bits for
everything but if you are using 16 bits
to store 8-bit characters you kind of
need to decide which way round are you
going to read them starting with the big
end or starting at the little end and so
the word delete in utf-16 if you take
apart the memory in your windows machine
and look at the raw numbers the word
delete is in there encoded like this
but if you flip those pairs around what
you get at the other end
is chinese the first i ran this through
google translate in case it was like a
ransom demand or something um and the
first one there is a character that
means putting a pearl in the mouth of a
deceased relative for burial and the
second one is preparing a duck for a
traditional feast so
like if this was hackers demanding
something i don't know what they wanted
um it's nonsense it's you know what had
happened is yeah this absolutely mapped
out we took a couple of sql statements
flipped the bits on them using a
little.net utility that we hacked
together and it's like yes this is
exactly what's going on next question
why is our sql server using big endian
instead of little envian why are the
bits getting flipped and it turns out
they weren't
this was in a data center in a private
sort of cloud hosting facility and they
had a bad network switch and about every
three minutes it would drop one byte
from the stream between our dynamic crm
box and the database server and when
that byte fell out everything else just
got shunted sideways and nothing had the
systems had no idea they're just like oh
well clearly there's chinese in the
event logs now all right i'll put it
over here in case it's important and
then they'd be like but actually you
can't run that that's not a valid sql
statement i'll log it here so yeah you
know that was a kind of real interesting
crash course on text encoding and uh you
know i learned this thing about windows
and and java and stuff they use 16 bits
internally for most things and so i
started thinking well okay so there's
ascii right figure that out and then
there's this utf-16 thing now when you
get out onto the web things get much
more interesting because on the web
network speed matters the size of your
data becomes important because it has a
cost the bigger it is the harder it is
to send stuff around and the slower it
is to get there now
let's take an html page which is uh so
this is the html for hello world and
this time it's in it's in ukrainian
cyrillic and
most html you know web pages even if
your web page is in korean or hebrew all
of the html tags are 7-bit ascii all of
your javascript and cs i hope all your
javascript is 7-bit ascii your css
should be 7-bit ascii our programming
languages are all based on ascii because
this is the whole thing you know
developers work with plain text and if
you encode this document using utf-16
the bits that actually need 16 bits are
here because the only stuff that doesn't
fit in regular ascii is the two tiny
snippets here that are in ukrainian
cyrillic and so all the rest of it half
of each of those bytes is null but we
need to send those nulls across the wire
if we are using utf-16 it is a really
inefficient serialization format in fact
44 of this page is redundant information
if we encode it with utf-16 and so along
comes what i think is one of the most
beautiful and brilliant hacks in the
history of technology anywhere um utf-8
encoding
now utf-8 says if you have a byte that
starts with a zero that is 7-bit ascii
1965 american flavor that stuff has not
changed every ascii document is a valid
utf-8 document as long as it's only
using 7-bit ascii
if you have any byte that starts with a
1 the 1 means this is part of a
multi-byte encoding sequence and if you
start with a 1-0 you are halfway through
a letter right now you are going to need
to backtrack a little bit until you find
one one and if you find one one zero
that one one means one two bytes if you
find one one one zero this is the
beginning of a three byte encoding
sequence if you find one one one one
zero that's a four byte encoding
sequence now utf-8 stops there because
once you get five six seven eight byte
encoding sequences you can't translate
those into anything else uh four byte
encoding can go into utf-32 which is
like utf-16 but it's twice as
inefficient but there is no utf-64
utf-128 but this does give us you know
this astonishing amount of headroom in
terms of being able to make up new uh
encodings for new alphabets and new
languages and uh you know it turns out
that we are not finished inventing
alphabets and languages yet we got all
these amazing ones around the world but
every once in a while someone goes hmm
maybe we could come up with a new one
now there is a completely new alphabet
that's been invented within my lifetime
that i bet good money most of you have
used already today
it is the language and alphabet called
emoji it came out of a
project a japanese mobile phone company
in the 1990s wanted to do like you know
weather forecasts and bus timetables and
uh they hired an artist to create them
this set of emoji that was uh on the
original the platform was called imode
and it ran a company called docomo and
this set of emoji is in the museum of
modern art in new york now and
this took off in a big way in japan like
within a year you couldn't sell a phone
in japan if it didn't have emoji support
so when apple in 2008 wanted to launch
iphone in japan it had to have emoji
and so people around the world were like
hey if you switch on japanese in your
iphone keyboard you can start sending
these little smiley faces and things and
as this spread around the world people
started asking some quite delicate
questions you know like uh okay emoji's
cool um the pilot the police officer the
chef the firefighter why are they all
men
and why are they all white men and
someone came out actually they're yellow
men and it's like no that's not even no
no no let's not even go there you know
and lots of people like why are there
they're tacos why is there sushi here
but there are no tacos why are there the
flags of these countries but the flag of
palestine is not included what are you
trying to tell me with this this set of
characters here now in 2015
unico took a massive step towards kind
of inclusivity with the way you can use
emoji to communicate and they did it in
a way that i thought was really clever
they added the ability to change the
skin tone that's used on faces and hands
and those kinds of emoji and they did it
using combining characters so the same
way that we put the little tail on the c
earlier this uh uf one one f44d code
point is the thumbs up has been for
years but they said well by the way this
is a combining character and if your
device handset can support it it will
combine these two characters and gives
you thumbs up with a modified skin tone
and now every year the unicode
consortium announces the new emoji and
they have all these you know astonishing
combinations of gender and identity and
family configurations and occupations
and all this kind of stuff and the way
they've done it all is to use the
flexibility that's built into the
unicode encoding standard if you want to
send someone an emoji of a female
astronaut what you actually send them is
a rocket ship
and then a thing called a zwitch a zero
width joiner and a rocket and if your
handset supports that version then it'll
combine the uh woman and the rocket and
give you female astronaut and you can
actually kind of stack these things you
can say we'll take a woman plus the dark
skin cone plus the zero with joyner plus
the rocket and so you can get female
astronauts with a variety of different
skin tones um if any of you was at the
meetup the other night scott helm said
something on the panel show i thought
was really cool he's like apple uh keep
putting out updates which are like get
these new emoji oh yeah and also this
update that security update that
security update and people will update
their phones to get new emoji people
don't care about security but the new
emoji is a really good way of getting
everyone to keep their operating system
up to date because they want all the new
shiny things now
there's an interesting uh detail about
one particular set of emoji which are
you know used an awful lot which is
flags um if you want to do the
i apologize for this i've changed the
coding but i have accidentally left the
flag of belarus in here um but if you
want to do the flag of norway in emoji
there is a block of alphabet letters
called the regional symbol indicators
and you do a regional symbol indicator n
plus o and that gives you the flag of
norway and if you forget to replace it
you get the flag of belarus if you want
to do the flag of england then england
is not a country according to the people
who make these kinds of decisions great
britain is a country the united kingdom
of great britain and it gets complicated
um the flag of england there's a block
in unicode called the alphabetical tags
and this was put in in 2010 because it
might be a good idea and then it was
taken out because they're like no one's
using this and then it was put back in
in a big hurry when they realized that
handset manufacturers were using this
for things like the flag of england
which didn't fit into the country block
you send a black flag and then you send
the tag latin letter small g-b-e-n-g
and this is how the flag of england is
encoded and the flag of scotland wales
and texas are also now part of the
unicode standard on that basis and the
pride flag is a white flag a zero with
joyner and a rainbow
now does anyone
know what country this flag belongs to
bonus points if you can tell me the
actual official name of the country that
this flag belongs to anybody
the republic of china is the correct
answer not to be confused with the
people's republic of china which is a
much bigger country on the other side of
the sea um the republic of china is the
country that most people know as taiwan
and in mainland china this flag is seen
as a symbol of support for taiwanese
independence and the people's republic
of china does not like the idea of
taiwanese independence now if you go
onto your iphone
and uh you go in and you write a text
message to somebody and you type in
taiwan it pops up hey you mean that and
you click the flag and there you go but
then you go into your regional settings
and you go i'm going to change my
phone's region to china mainland and
then i'm going to go back to my emoji
and look at that the flag has
disappeared
and it doesn't appear on the keyboard
anymore
this is apple's solution to how to sell
iphone to the three billion people in
china who eventually are going to want
iphones now this is a kind of weird
thing this is apple's solution to the
fact that flags can be very very
political and can cause all kinds of
problems with international trade and
stuff if you go onto my twitter profile
i have a couple of flags in there the eu
one and the fact that i'm in norway
right now and if you want to go in and
edit my profile on mac os it looks like
the one on the left on windows you get
the thing on the right spot the
difference
windows has no flags
the only flags in microsoft windows are
the pirate skull and crossbones and the
gay pride flag so windows position on
flags is that gay pirates are okay and
everyone else can get in the bin
which you know what would you do what
would your solution be um and so if you
actually the twitter web interface what
that does is it injects pngs so it
replaces the operating system's native
emoji with its own emoji character set
um but yeah there are no flag emojis on
microsoft windows still now
there's one more little detail that i
want to leave you with actually two more
little details i want to leave you with
um one if you remember when we were
talking about francois the archaeologist
we had that little weird the a and the e
kind of meshed together now that's not a
letter of an alphabet the underlying
text there is still just regular 7-bit
ascii what that is it is a rendering
concept called a ligature if you have a
look at the the logo type for my my
company you'll see that the t and the i
are kind of stuck together now this is
just text and it's text rendered in a
typeface called lato and lato includes
ligatures so when you have a t and an i
if the operating system and the platform
supports it there's a little thing says
hey use this character for that pair
instead because it looks nice and the
awesome thing about ligatures is you can
use them in programming fonts so you can
take a chunk of code and you can set it
i don't recognize this language
now the language is f sharp this is is
fizzbuzz in f sharp um the actual source
code looks like that if you render it in
an ordinary mono spaced font but this is
being rendered using a typeface called
fire a code which has rules in it that
like hey the little minus sign followed
by the bracket that's an arrow so let's
draw that as an arrow a little vertical
pipe with a thing that's a triangle draw
that as a triangle so and fire code
includes a whole bunch of of concepts
for this like the triple equality in
javascript in fire code it's three bars
one above the other which i absolutely
love you know one i think it makes code
look cool and i like things that look
cool it also makes it more readable it
makes it easier to see if you've missed
a double equals that should have been a
triple equals and and all these kinds of
things so uh go and check out fire code
there's now this was the first one that
did it there's now a whole bunch of
programming fonts out there that use
ligatures to kind of do cool stuff with
how they represent programming language
operators and things
and finally
i want to share the the third little
turning point on my personal journey
with texting coding with you because a
few years ago i had the the great
pleasure of visiting ukraine for the
first time and uh i had a blast it's an
awesome country if you get a chance you
should totally go there and i'm walking
around and i can't even read the
alphabet like i have no idea what
anything says i can't read the menus i
can't read the road signs i can't read
the billboards i can read the license
plates on the cars
and i thought yeah that's really weird
why would ukraine use the english
alphabet for their vehicle license
plates but they use the cyrillic
alphabet for everything else and so i
did a bit of digging and i turned at a
weird coincidence 1965 the same year as
ascii there was a thing called the
vienna convention on road traffic which
was this big international treaty signed
by a basically every country in europe
about what you had to do if you wanted
to drive your car across the border and
one of the things that all the countries
signed up to including the soviet union
was any vehicle crossing a border can
only use the latin alphabet on its
license plates i mean okay they signed
that and uh somebody said now soviet
license plates in 1965 looked like this
and i'm guessing that there was a
meeting somewhere where someone said
comrade how have we signed the vienna
convention when our license plates look
like this and someone else says no one
is driving their car out of the soviet
union that's just not a thing that's
going to happen um if you did if you
could get the travel permits and
everything because you know the ussr was
still a closed country um they would
give you temporary license plates at the
border and i'm assuming if you didn't
bring them back you would be in a lot of
trouble
then when the ussr you know collapsed in
the 1990s and uh russia and ukraine and
belarus all these countries became
independent they took the opportunity to
overhaul their vehicle registration
systems and so today the license plates
in those countries look like this
and the way they did it is they took the
cyrillic alphabet and the latin alphabet
and they looked for the intersection
they looked for the set of they're not
letters they are glyphs they are things
that are the same shape even if they're
not necessarily the same sound and they
said this is the set of characters we
will use on our vehicle registration
plates and if you take that set of
characters in english and you shuffle
them around a little bit
they spell pike matchbox
and so that's a little shibboleth for
all of you next time somebody says to
you oh i'm sending you this file it'll
be fine it's plain text you can turn
around to them and go do you know pike
matchbox and if they say oh yeah yeah
then they've been to this talk and they
know about big endian and little ending
and code pages and utf-8 and
teleprinters and the cook and wheatstone
telegraph system and you can have a
civilized conversation about what plain
text actually means but if they say i'm
sending you a plain text file yeah
you'll be able to read it and you say do
you know pike matchbox and they go
what's pike matchbox you should hang
onto your hat because you have no idea
what they are going to send you
thank you very much
[Applause]
you